un député socialiste dénonce les
ministres qui se comportent dit-il en
enfant gâté de la République le
Gouvernement c'est l'équipe de France de
naissna dit-il en référence à la à la
Coupe du monde en Afrique du Sud et
c'est signé Jean-Christophe cambadellis
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec sa
vision je vais le dire autrement je ve
dire qu'il faut un peu plus de sens
collectif voilà c'est oui il faut jouer
collectivement c'està-dire qu'il faut
pas essayer de tirer la couverture à soi
pour se mettre en valeur on est dans une
ambition collective celle de redresser
la France et nous le FA c le président
de la République donc on doit être
respectueux de la fonction qu'on a c'est
une occasion pour moi de le dire à tous
les ministres jouer collectif